so my mom passed away last night um
we're back at her house in wyoming
and it's just weird that she's
not coming back through the door ever i
i'm sort of stunned and i'm sort of at a
loss
my mom
was diagnosed with cancer
and there just was really no good way
to operate
i was trying to make arrangements to
bring her back down to
to me so that i could take care of her
but she just at that point was too sick
she couldn't travel
it went completely downhill
and so i rushed there and was able to
spend the last
few hours with her that she was alive
[Music]
i'm currently driving by myself early in
the morning sun's coming up in the east
grandma cheryl has passed away and i'm
headed to her funeral she's janelle's
mom
there's a strange relationship that we
have in this mary and janelle were
friends and then i became friends with
janelle janelle introduced cheryl her
mother
to my dad
and they get married
my dad ended up marrying cheryl before i
married janelle
so it's weird that cheryl is both my
dad's wife my mom's sister wife and my
mother-in-law
it's been basically
nine months
since i saw grandma cheryl the funeral
is only a little over a week not even 10
days
before we'd be gathering for christmas
and travel and stuff like that but i've
asked
robin and mary to not go to the funeral
i just don't want them
getting exposure to the virus
robin's the wife that i can communicate
with and say hey i don't think you
should go and she's like okay i won't
i'm hoping and praying with faith that
we'll make it to this
celebration for christmas in spite of
going
and having potential exposure to kovid
the funeral however is more important in
this case i feel
than christmas